foreign
look man I've been pushing back this
update on the date and stuff because
it's [__] depressing but we gotta get
through it we got to get through it so
there's a couple quick things here uh
this is his dad passed away we mentioned
that
um R.I.P yeah so here's title of this
video is family essentially laughs it up
arrogantly downstairs during the time of
grieving dad passing away
They're laughing because human beings
that have emotions when people pass away
it's very complex
sometimes you will laugh because you'll
remember something that the person did
that made you happy and then you're
gonna cry and it's going to hurt and
it's going to suck if everything's a
whole [__] deal it's not just it's
not just one thing Dayton it's not just
spiraling about your your skinhead
brother who beat you
beautiful laugh too like a sad one yeah
[__] up man oh okay strap in oh you
gotta leave so you're lucky everyone
else strap in God damn it
yeah first remember guys Dayton's not
trapped in here with us we're trapped in
here with him yeah basically so his new
thing is by the way
um I've been been sent some Facebook
screenshots here
he is needs a girlfriend he needs a
girlfriend to move in with him that way
it'll be easier for him to get the house
when uh his mom dies he's publicly
saying that like that's not me that's
he's saying that you
emotionless [__]
I know Frozen it's he's not he's he's
[__] terrible but he not only is he
terrible but I don't get the logic like
if you have a girlfriend are you gonna
be able to double up and beat up your
mom and take the house I don't get why I
don't know
because like if I had a kid like if my
son was a worthless piece of [__] like
girl
and I was dying and then he thought oh
yeah if I move a girl in here then he
won't like take the Hat I'd be like no
you and this dumb [__] get the [__] out
what are you doing yeah I mean it's I
was thinking like maybe if I can get her
to start getting mail sent here you know
that's you know yes yes and then like
they can't take the house from us
if I don't find a girlfriend to move in
with me I truly don't know how I'm going
to endure living here without dad he was
always the best listener to my troubles
for psoriasis uh to things uh to things
about me that I didn't realize was
autism because that info was kept from
me with a girlfriend living here there's
a way better acceptable feminine energy
in the house than my mom could accept in
her pre-mid 20th century upbringing
absolutely all right I need a girlfriend
only good memories of his father is just
him bitching at him yeah yes he was a
listener that's the only good thing
about him because see he's what you call
[__] sociopath who only cares about
his [__] self and now if my dad does
I'm not gonna be able to borrow his car
I need a girlfriend go get my health
burritos
stupid [__]
I'm laughing because it's real that he
said those things you know what I mean
like it's
what's that song and the troon's in the
corner filming with his phone
as he's all alone
so it turns out when you're leaving home
son I don't know when
but that died and he passed away so
that's that's like half as many credit
cards I can steal for pizzas and I'm not
I don't know what I'm gonna do I need a
girlfriend so I can steal her credit
card he is
and that's what he's all upset he
doesn't have as many credit cards to get
his hands on now
um
so this is um
this is them you know whatever they're
laughing he's mad and then he uh I'm
gonna go ahead and get to the one that I
really really been trying to get to so
uh
uh here it is he posted this video he
was drunk a 17-minute video he took it
down
right but luckily but wait a minute then
how do you have it well here's the thing
merge
luckily one of our fans who of course
we're not gonna it makes it's better if
we don't but thank you Dave wish uh
Steve's way better than this guy
um no kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding um
luckily there's a channel called
hypernova backups
that we have access to and um
wanna
Frozen
yeah I need you to meditate this is
gonna be really hard okay now I want you
to set the stage okay I'm gonna set the
stage for you ready
his
father just passed away his mother is in
totally grieving
just doing very poorly
the title of this video was my
transphobic mom who allowed a skinhead
to beat me repeatedly in her house she's
75 years old now ready
oh
not ever
I respected everything that was said
a tough person if this person's gonna
live in my house mom you are not the
person that has the authority in the
situation
it's her house
and you said this is the day after this
is the day I want to say day and a half
yeah does say two days two days two days
Jesus Christ
yeah I hope all right I hope the fumes
reach him no they will oh don't worry
they will we should get I'm gonna buy
date in a place right by where they
[__] exploded the [__] the trains
you need to respect that charge no you
are not in charge no you are not lawyers
are always in charge
um she's the one paying for the lawyers
and you
think get yourself you're going to be
observing that
Mom that's not a pep that is not a
future I I am going to tell you if you
want to do something you'll have to get
a lawyer lawyers are already involved
really Mom
Mom this was not recent good good
because I'll have Danny give you Dan is
all
hmm
a taper Dayton terrorizes his grieving
mother is the title of this one already
you're looking right in camera talking
about Dan he will come over you're
saying it in a present you are saying in
such a tense or such a you're oh by the
way update the family kindly declined to
go fund me
they said that they do not just so you
know the person that we had contact with
they they did the family they they don't
they don't want hand they don't want to
hand out they said they appreciate it
but they don't want to hand out just so
you guys know we really tried and they
said no we'll be all right they say they
don't like taking handouts so gotta get
it even makes me like this mother even
more if you know
Mom you are pretty
mom you're putting it into a connotation
in which he is nothing more than a
utilization tool Dan is a decent human
being who listens to people he does not
utilize in such ways because I'm gonna
do a will here's the thing Dayton the
only reason you're in that you were in
that house for as long as you were is
because your father was protecting you
your mother didn't want you there we
remember the history
she he talked her out of kicking you out
your whole protection layer is gone and
if you think by some sort of magic of
having some sort of girlfriend that's
willing to touch your flaky dick is
going to get you that house you are 100
wrong because she's right
yeah flaky dick Dayton yeah yeah you
lost your [__] your Boogeyman and
your brother now you lost your protector
and your dad so now you're all alone now
you're gonna lose the house because she
just brought up the W word mm-hmm she
just said I'm getting a will uh oh sorry
you're gonna leave the house too uh the
flaky skin [__] trans degenerate
who's never showed a grounds of
appreciation or love for his family or
the daughter and the son-in-law that
have kids that have been involved in the
family all day I don't know what do you
think's gonna get the house but what but
get ready to get angry because I know
you're mad before but listen to this mom
your will has very little to do with
past 10 situations
playing to you Mom you do not exploit
things selfishly
mom Dayton hypernova just said Dayton
hypernova just said you do not exploit
things okay
um yeah
yeah are you selfish person I had a
state you know that's the one thing
about Damon's mother that we've always
said she's a very selfish person
horrible the whole the way they treat
him you know that you live there
bought you your health burritos I have
literally had him thrown in jail yeah
the credit card stuff and they made it
because remember he let it slip they
made they were doing stuff I'm just
gonna say this they were just doing
stuff to make sure that he kept getting
his social like his government checks
for his craziness of course because his
son and even though he's crazy they were
trying to help him you know
and out in the cold tonight and then get
yelled out after the oh by the way why
are they in the car together immerse you
may be asking
funeral no no no no no she was at a
funeral
um she had to pick him up from the bar
because he was drinking
he didn't even attend the [__]
funeral no
Frozen he's in pain
so she drinking himself until he dies he
she picked him up
from a bar after the day after his
father died
I want to see Frozen whoop this dude's
ass he's grieving
fact of telling you that I was already
standing out in the cold and you made a
personal agenda on your part and then
turned it around and say that you were
the victim no Mom that she is the victim
she in every conceivable way she's the
victim in this situation everybody
involved in a Dayton hypernova story arc
is a victim a view of you of Dayton
hypernova yeah that is gaslighting
that is a major problem these days in
people who have wealth and have an ego
problem about their wealth
they live in Dayton Ohio they're not
wealthy they're flaunting their wealth
and they they're not wealthy what are
you talking about whoa Mr retirement
fund early bird special
you mean of the uh of course there if
you look up middle class old money if
you look up middle class in the
dictionary that's what his family is you
know
Royce uh it's 2023 that means you're
rich oh that's right good point ah yes
the vast Plantation the Dayton shelters
you don't have that right anymore there
may have been an arrow where you would
have had half that [__] narrative and
I am sorry for it's like a Dayton
hypernova Yellowstone thing wealthy
landowners of Dayton Ohio
Kurt Russell walking with a cowboy hat
on that's Kurt Russell in the dark
filming yeah beats me on this Ranch
costing a little bit but it is angering
a person who was standing out in the
cold in 20 degree weather your father
just died
laughs
draw a million things you throw a
million things out there I was beaten
in that house yeah that's right
Mama no no you're sick you're sick get
him Mama Schultz get him Mama Schultz
we're on your side
sitting right here in the car next to
you was not sick during the beatings I
was perfectly well
no Mom it's gonna oh he's so scared he's
so scared of her the I'm telling you
remember remember you were of course you
remember Marsh the only thing protecting
him from the mother kicking him out was
the dad
that's the only thing because the sister
wants him out of that house too the one
that lives across the street wants him
out too they want him [__] out all
had it with him yeah would be a bad
thing if they do you need to pray to the
god that took all that was good in our
lives dad was a decent person
and he went to a good place
oh he's a decent person now after you
the things you said about your father
he had a conscience so the person who's
sitting right next to me who's
exploiting any pain in her life about
Peter rolling her eyes and looking just
she's just looking wait a minute I'm
sorry she's exploiting her pain yeah
obviously she's exploiting her pain yes
obviously oh I hate him to turn it into
what don't you understand immersion I'm
sorry it's really clear if we're not
keeping up with this dating story arc
something where she can turn against
people around her how long are you gonna
milk this one tragedy yeah I don't know
man do you remember when he talked
hardcore [__] on his dad because he
ordered pizza from the pizza place he
didn't link because I remember that
price 120. I know I know buddy
sin seriously has a problem that is an
illness
[Music]
all going to change Mom it's going to be
a bad she literally just drives off the
[__] Bridge
yes things are finally Gonna Change
around here
let's go right off a [__] dock
[Music]
if she just rolled out and survived and
got up unless she just goes in the water
and she does a
wonder if Sizzler's open and just walks
away
as he's shouting you will not leave me
in this car she merged in water
you want it to be bad that has
everything to do with your inconsistency
he's hammered by the way consideration
in the situation but I have been
conscious I have been conscientious he
has to drink all the feelings away yeah
What feelings in the situation
and I have kept it on record because
it's absolutely appalling oh a matter of
record by the way we've been keeping
record too don't worry your honor I
would like to submit uh uh 200 videos
that are 50 minutes long I've been
muttering alone in my bedroom as proof
as exhibit a all right listen here I
don't like it I'm gonna allow it but I'm
watching you
all right rejection your honor he's
trying to bore this courtroom to death
all right we're gonna have to comb the
evidence objection do we we have to can
we just know
but you make a [__] big deal out of
me yes we went through all the videos
your honor and he mentions Health
burritos of total of 432 yes
I'd like to move to uh based on this new
evidence coming to light I'd like to
dismiss this case on the ground that
he's a massive
let the record show let the record show
that he was not beaten in this house
of the place that you now I may just be
an old southern boy
but I don't think I'd like to submit
this affidavit that states that he
wasn't in fact beaten enough in that
house
signed by everybody in the lgbtq Dayton
Dayton Ohio community
I went out there and a bunch of these
said they would come out and kick his
ass for them
now call me old-fashioned but we used to
beat these fellas in the street if I do
declare I got here 14 sworn statements
by people in the lgbtq community saying
that they would love to hate crime you
one of the one of the one of the Bears
in the community said he wanted to show
his preferred pronouns they and them
laughs
nobody likes you Dayton went to pick me
up and took it personally that I wasn't
where you were parked at which was two
blocks away it was like it was a solid
block away well I'm not gonna say it's
two blocks away it was more than far
enough away that I had to walk out to
where by the way if you like this give
it a like on Rumble
he doesn't like the [__] curbs he
doesn't like it unless it's curbside
ballet service
like an Uber driver and he's annoyed
that he had to cross the street this was
one of those Uber blacks that James
O'Keefe was talking about pissed you off
something Royal I thought black Uber was
just Lyft but I was confused
oh no are you kidding me if James
O'Keefe used Dayton as a Honey Pop you'd
never get anything done that's true it'd
be five hour videos I'm talking to a
Pfizer employee about how he gets beat
in the house ouch
out front of blind box that's where you
parked
no one was in your way is what you're
saying no one was
yeah I need that could I have that I
need that yeah I'll pack it up actually
yeah okay give me a moment okay it's
four minutes and uh ten to and seven
seconds
hey just give me a second just holding
up a dog
[Music]
okay I'm ready when you are Mom that's
where you parked
no one was
no one was in your way
oh my God you just want the uh yeah I
just want her
yeah
look dating your dad's dad
hey I found the person who's gonna
replace Justin roll in his [__] Rick
and Morty
Rick
[Laughter]
no one was in you I said oh I have to go
out he was cold as [__] outside
then don't go what is wrong with you I
love her
she's Unleashed now boy she's Unleashed
now Mom
someone it was not that cold when I left
and it was that cold when you picked me
up that should be understandable no you
do not act like a belligerent [__] to
the person who is yeah you stop acting
like a belligerent [__] lady you're
being nut ma'am you're being a little
unhinged do you see that situation I
have gone seven years without talking
about like Authority that he doesn't
have or deserve or super weird right
it's super easy let's just say he went
seven years without talking about
Sherman beating him yeah he's seven
years it's literally all you talk about
it's the only thing you talk about
by the way guys I want to point out if
you're new here because there's some new
people you want to know the whole Baxter
of Dayton it's a fascinating piece we
have we have a clip we have a clip
Channel a search ROTC clips on YouTube
and uh just there's there's a playlist
Dayton hypernova watch from beginning to
end it's a wonderful story arc uh and
also all the clips are on Rumble as well
I just need to be able to make playlists
on Rumble please let me make playlists
on Rumble thank you check check the show
drops I made it yeah oh bye I'll grab it
hey by the way did you did you see that
Rumble does have a pop-out chat now
a word yep you could pop the chat out
now which is way easier for a lot of
people hey nice
yeah this looks pretty uh it's it's
coming together
all right let's see
[__] out of me regularly no it's gonna
be on regular whoa
sorry for somebody who thinks they got
beat up I've got beat and it's all
record person no record you know we've
watched all of your videos dating every
single one and the only thing that we
ever saw on record of anybody being
assaulted was you breaking a wine glass
over Sherman's head that was the only
time that anyone hit anybody in that
house on video whatever you say right
now is on record oh it was
what are you talking about you're
talking about the second beating yes
what about every other bidding after
that Mom I got beat year after year
after year
so take you to the hospital no no it
doesn't matter the police
now that's the reason to bring up the
police we bring to the hospital when we
talked about it before the social
service you know the social special the
[__] police know him
oh yeah I remember we've seen the video
yeah yeah oh here it is hold on thank
you for coming they're like hey Earl
Mercy could grab it from the show drops
nice thank you
Frozen some people have cough buttons
merch has the opposite he has cough
drops
merch you have to can you make it can
you can you do something where you sync
it up and you make it so that when you
hit your cough button it plays that
sound like
[Laughter]
you won't have anything to say to the
lawyers the lawyers will be involved
no Mom it'll be bad it'll be bad
[Music]
he gets paid a hundred dollars to do
laundry I'll have you know that he
spends on booze at a local bar
well the problem is it's like you know
and gets paid that hundred dollar by the
person he's gonna Sue so yeah that's
gonna be complicated
is he thinks he's too good for gross
under the bridge sex
where he could make a killing
he'll never do it gross gross under the
bridge sex is pretty funny
see what they have to say you know this
doesn't matter this doesn't matter to me
this this interaction doesn't matter me
what matters to me is how our
interaction hasn't taken mom you're not
gonna have anything to say about this
you're gonna be
oh yeah girl when I'm gone uh for those
asking I posted the link in the chat but
if you want to start just go to ROTC
Eclipse it's on the page or just search
Dayton hypernova uh Dayton hyper Dayton
hypernova Saga and you'll get the
playlist because you guys should catch
up this has been fascinating to cover
when you're gone it's going to be a
convenience to you
whoa what oh what what let me back that
up sorry okay let's hear that again I
did let me hear that I got to hear that
again
you know this doesn't matter this
doesn't matter to me this this
interaction doesn't matter me what
matters to me is how our interaction has
to take you some Place mom you're not
gonna have anything to say about this
you're gonna be
girl when I'm gone when you're gone it's
going to be a convenience to you
what you ease off it'll be a convenience
to him because she because she is she
sucks anyway because she remember she's
pre-industrial Revenue when she call I
don't know stupid like that Tori and era
yeah Victorian era mindset no no mob you
what you're saying is this when you're
gone it's going to be convenient to you
God you're saying that when you are gone
it's going to be convenient to you
regardless no no no no no no that's not
what you're saying what you're saying no
no no what you are saying you have to
find that has nothing to do with
anything else
stuff no you harass the house
mom
you're using you're utilizing a luxury
mindset you are using luxury mindset
she's not he's mad because she's not
leaving the house in the will to him and
she's going to sell it that's all this
is about cool he's panicking good good
all you had to be was nice
no I have complete understanding of that
situation well then you understand and
then he is going to have to do gross
under the bridge sex for money because
he's gonna be left with no other [__]
God he wants to have gross under the
bridge sex with her I'm not even for
free you don't think so I mean I've seen
some groceries it's like you're banging
too [__] around
it's like LeBron it's like LeBron before
a game
it's
like in the other guys when they when
they crash their Prius into the cocaine
and it's all over the car these [__]
guys that are doing the strong man
things yeah entire ropes
they just ate a box of powdered Donuts
cause I'm watching some fat Bosnian guy
lifting ambulance
it's like it's refining up finding a
book in a haunted mansion
did you with the record uh fidelisource
in the chats and how long until he's
living out of a car he doesn't have he
doesn't have a car
he Ubers everywhere and when he can't
afford that his mom has to pick him up a
day after the dad died
dude if you're facing homelessness and
you own a car there's always that okay
look I do have the car like I'm not
going to be sleeping out in the elements
you know what I mean but he don't even
have that
imagine if he eventually has to end up
sleeping
in a box that had the health health
burritos too
behind the pizza place
City like from frisky dingo
oh mark my word she's gonna sell that
place she's gonna have to get removed
from that house oh [__]
oh so you're telling me you're living in
a refrigerator box from the company that
used to they used to own that made the
refrigerators
they're like sir you can't we bought the
house you need to leave and he's like
I'll do your laundry for a hundred
dollars a week
no get out
so that's the end of that clip but
here's what we're gonna do
um I'm gonna if you're on locals revenge
of assist.locals.com and the five dollar
level I'm gonna upload that entire 16
minute video if you guys want to skim
through and tell me we missed anything
worth playing you can or just if you
want to be mad by yourself you can see
the entire story it's kind of like the
background stuff like you know HBO every
time we watch a show now it's like stay
tuned for the making of the show extras
and I'm like I don't want to see that I
don't care what the director thought
okay so this is why I'm having trouble
getting people to sign up on the locals
because this is what we're offering them
yeah raging raw [__] Dayton hypernova
vids